das ist wirklich ziemlich verblüffend
dieses schwarze loch in mini größe hat
nur die 3,3 fache masse der sonne
damit ist diese entdeckung eines
forschungsteams eine ganz besondere denn
solch ein dermaßen kleines schwarzes
loch war bislang noch nicht bekannt dazu
kommt es sendet weder im sichtbaren noch
im röntgen spektrum strahlung aus und so
sind die fachleute überzeugt dass dieses
schwarze loch auf eine ganz neue klasse
dieser kosmischen objekte hindeutet
klick zum science fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannen des seins videos
abonniert den kanal und aktivierte
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
diese außergewöhnliche entdeckung eines
forschungsteams gelang auf ganz
besondere art und weise
denn normalerweise spüren fachleute
schwarze löcher auf indem sie nach
intensiver röntgenstrahlung ausschau
halten diese entsteht wenn schwarze
löcher materie aus ihrer umgebung
verschlingen das material wird in die
massereichen objekte gerissen und dabei
erhitzt so verraten sich schwarze löcher
also durch röntgenstrahlung doch das us
forschungsteam ging anders vor
die fachleute machten sich die arbeit
und analysierten die daten von rund
100.000 sternen der milchstraße vor
allem interessierten sie sich für die
spektren die mit dem galactic evolution
experiment am abtransport observatorium
in new mexico gesammelt wurden 200
sterne kamen dann in die engere auswahl
und wurden ganz intensiv analysiert hier
suchten die fachleute vor allem nach
regelmäßigen blau und rot verschiebungen
denn diese erlauben rückschlüsse auf
einen unbekannten begleiter der sterne
die farbverschiebungen deuten nämlich
darauf hin dass solch einen unsichtbaren
begleiter die sterne von der erde weg
und wieder in unsere richtung bewegt
durch diese methode wurde das us
forschungsteams an auf einen roten
riesen aufmerksam
so werden in der fachwelt große
leuchtkräftige aber eher kühle sterne
bezeichnet es handelt sich um den stern
mit dieser bezeichnung die werde ich
jetzt nicht aussprechen
das schwarze loch in seiner nähe wurde
also einzig und allein durch die
bewegung des sterns aufgespürt eine
echte premiere
und auch das schwarze loch selbst ist
eine entdeckung die überrascht denn es
ist eben so klein wie bislang noch kein
anderes jemals aufgespürt des schwarzes
loch doch wie kann das sein dass us
forschungsteam
ist sich sicher dass es sich um eine
ganz neue klasse von schwarzen löchern
handelt möglicherweise ist es also nur
eines von vielen die den expertinnen
experten bislang alle durch die lappen
gegangen sind bisher ging man nämlich
davon aus dass schwarze löcher
mindestens die 5 fache masse der sonne
aufweisen müssten die vorstände
appellieren jetzt die skala der
schwarzen löcher zu erweitern die neue
methode schwarzen löchern mit hilfe der
bewegung von sternen auf die schliche zu
kommen sei gut geeignet um weitere
dieser kleinen kosmische objekte
aufzuspüren schon ab der 2,1 fache masse
der sonne könnten also schwarze löcher
existieren die aber kaum oder gar nicht
mit der materie in ihrer umgebung
interagieren somit gelangen der erste
nachweis solch eines vertreters ja auch
erst jetzt das forschungsteam aus den
usa ist sich sicher deren folgen ihrer
anziehungskraft auf andere himmelskörper
könnte weitere schwarze löcher dieser
neuen klasse verraten dazu schreibt das
autorenteam in der aktuellen studie
möglicherweise gibt es eine population
von ähnlich verborgenen schwarzen
löchern die durch die bisherigen röntgen
beobachtungen übersehen wurden
was passiert in einem schwarzen loch
dieses video hier anklicken anschauen
und doktor watson den megafonen kanal
abonnieren bis dann bleib dran